hey youtubers is Charlie how the tables
have turns this is going to be my
Walking Dead episode 11 video careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
hands down one of the funniest awkward
eugene episodes ever it felt like a
Dwight episode for most of it was
actually a Eugene Dwight episode just
showing how they kind of flit places
from the beginning of the episode to the
end of the episode so there's a new
round of the walking dead giveaway it's
for a $20 Amazon gift card all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video about the
episode so let's make this top 12 WTF
and comic book Easter eggs just because
the episode went about eight minutes
longer than a normal episode even though
the Oscars are on tonight too so let me
know if you watch this instead of
watching the Oscars but here we go
number 12
Eugene and Dwight's entrance slowly
cranking up the WTF like the music
starts to build like you think that
they're taking Eugene to one of the
cells you see Dwight's
face start to melt as he realizes that
Daryl's gone he starts rifling through
all his stuff he starts putting the
pieces together and then big record drop
moment is when they take Eugene to a
really nice special room in Dwight
realized that he is completely screwed
he's just waiting for negan in his room
so number 11 just the most beautiful way
to cut that tension is Eugene asking
about room service can I have lobster no
you can't have freaking lobster what are
you kidding
how about pickles we have fresh potato
chips we have someone makes so he starts
rifling through the pantry in his room
there's like a fridge he basically has
everything that you would need to be
comfortable and then pushes a CD player
and it's the Easy Street song so just as
the music builds this is beautiful
moment where you see Dwight getting the
crap beat out of him like oh my god how
the tables have turned
it just reminds you of his time with
Daryl so the big thing here is like
you're really starting to get worried
about Eugene because it seems like he is
really going to be on easy street the
real moment that you start to get
worried though is when you're like oh my
god does this mean that Eugene is going
to settle in and start being a crap bag
like the rest of the Savior's the whole
song has a completely different context
for Dwight just given what happened with
Darrell's character but it's a more
literal reference for Eugene's character
he is literally on easy street as long
as he can lie his ass off so the mullet
of Lies comes back remember when that
came out a couple seasons ago when they
all figured out that he was lying to
them so
he had to roll that out again in this
episode it was so funny because it's
almost a repeat of exactly what he told
Abraham when he first met him way back
at the beginning of the apocalypse so 10
Dwight wakes up in the cell and you
learn what his Ark is going to be this
episode he has to find sherry negan is
slowly figuring things out he starts to
make things up he really likes to write
his own backstory he'd be a great
fiction novelist so he reminds Dwight
about the last time this happened the
last time he was in the cell and you
just see the look on Dwight's face like
he's slowly processing it you don't
really tell what he's thinking he just
so confused it sounds like he's not
totally convinced but the handwriting
looks so feminine that that was the
first conclusion I think most of us drew
were like okay that definitely does not
look like Dwight's handwriting so it's
got to be sherry that led him out but he
has to track her down so it takes them
back to their family home number 9
though bouncing back to Eugene one of
the funniest parts of the episode is him
with the pickle jar having to talk to
negan so he like he learns the economy
and they're like okay their points you
take what you want so he just learns how
things work there but then he just takes
the jar while he's talking to me gets
just waiting to get his brains bashed in
and then negan is like you're smarty
pants aren't you
why don't you solve a problem for me so
he just goes on and on
tells him all the Abraham lives I worked
at the CDC it's confidential
I have PhDs I'm a doctor like he
literally tells him every lies that he
can come up with that's actually his
special skill he actually does have some
real skills but his special skill is
just lying on command it's definitely
going to get him into a little bit of
trouble but number eight the big problem
that he solves for negan is the defense
system so this is going to be important
for future episodes so he's actually
helping negan fortify the sanctuary by
just pouring molten metal over the
walkers to just keep them from falling
apart and keep them in place
so nice call back for last week's
episode Eugene is helping them create a
whole bunch of Winslow's that are just
completely fortified it'll make it that
much harder for people to assault the
compound but don't forget about the
super hoard that's something that they
didn't address in this episode but you
got to know there's a trap that they
laid in that earlier episode it's going
to be something that will come back
later the super hoard is still very much
a thing
but number seven as a reward he gets to
hang out with the wife
no sex that's a big no-no so they're
just playing games it's so hilarious for
a moment it gets really awkward then he
shows them some science tricks gets in
good with them they actually seem like
they're pretty cool with them except for
the amber one who just getting drunk the
whole time but I just loved the little
show that he puts on like he doesn't
know like they get so excited and he
doesn't know what to do he just like
thank you thank you very much this is
nice so just more really bunny Eugene
humor there's really only a couple
emotions that you can detect on him one
is fear you can see when he's super
afraid peeing his pants too
crying when he's either really relieved
or really afraid and then three when
he's happy he just kind of makes like a
little smile at the side of his face
it's so funny
but bouncing back to Dwight number five
he learns the truth about what sherry
did so she left her rings and she let
Daryl go to sort of give him the push
that he needed to leave the savior's so
all she wants is to be free and for him
to be free and she felt like if she was
still theirs and that wouldn't happen
because he would stay to protect her so
she's removing herself from the equation
but there's a really heartfelt note and
you see them comparing the handwriting
like he's putting two and two together
like oh my god she did do this so what
am I going to do about it so I love that
has a little beer moment because she
referenced like them meeting up if they
ever got separated this was going to be
their happily ever after you bring some
beer and snacks and we'd meet up with
each other so that's sort of his way of
saying goodbye to her like leaving
flowers at someone's grave so she is
kind of dead to him but maybe they'll
meet up again because unless you see a
body she's not dead yet but he goes back
and tells them that she's dead so that
they won't go looking for her bouncing
back to Eugene number for the wives come
back and now they're super in tight with
Eugene they love him they're like will
you help us with amber she wants to kill
herself she didn't sign up for this life
so you slowly see the morality in
Eugene's head like the morality Mouse
jumps on the wheel and he's starting to
do the calculations would a good person
do this am i a good person do I want to
capitulate to this so true to form he is
a coward and agrees to help them
probably thinking he's doing the right
thing but he's probably so afraid and
still in shock that he's not thinking
straight at all so he goes he gets the
pills and you start to see some warning
signs where he
demands the pills like he's slowly
acting more like a savior you take what
you want so he like he turns back around
is like I'm the new chief engineer so he
lies some more he's really good at lying
but then number three before we can find
out what happened later we find out the
Dwight has framed the doctor for the
whole Shari Darryl escape mess and negan
throws him into the furnace you're going
to want to be here to see this but it's
a good thing we have a spare dr. Carson
so I think he's talking about Eugene
like he feels like Eugene does mr.
smartypants so he can do all the things
that dr. Carson would do so that
actually puts Eugene in a really bad
place because he can lie really well but
now the pressures on for him to deliver
so the simple engineering projects are
really easy for him but when somebody
needs some serious medical attention
he's not going to be able to do anything
so just a crazy way to go down but I
love the way the camera was focusing on
Dwight's face the whole time negan was
spinning another backstory like I said
he loves to make up his own backstory so
you did this you let Darrel go because
you wanted to get in good with Shari you
wanted to be together so it's really in
this moment that it sounds like it's not
so much Dwight trying to save himself
it's him starting to formulate a plan
about how he does not want to be a
savior anymore like everybody says I am
negan that's the big thing he's slowly
pulling away from that but you don't
really know exactly what he's going to
do about it so number two Eugene is now
negan's best friend sort of flipping the
script from the beginning of the episode
where Dwight was hardcore
mr. negan we need to go by the system
the system works this is how we survive
but I just love Eugene's line where he
stops negan before he can finish asking
his question I was negan before I met
you I just needed to see you to be sure
about it like after the wives came back
and he you know put two and two together
it was like you wanted me to kill negan
but I'm a coward so I'm not going to do
that because he's so worried about what
will happen if he's not successful or
it's more of a devil you know situation
like he knows that negan needs him so he
won't hurt him and that's why by his
logic negan believed Dwight over the
doctor because Dwight was more essential
than the doctor because he had Eugene so
Eugene is necessary and he doesn't want
to
get rid of the person who thinks that
he's necessary so he is now negan's best
friend whether or not he truly believes
that in his heart he is definitely going
to toe the line so number one that
intact with Dwight in Eugene who are now
completely opposite from where their
characters were at the beginning of the
episode where Dwight was mr. negan and
Eugene was pissing his pants like he
actually wanted nothing to do with what
was going on so he's eating the pickle
he's telling them how to fortify the
fence in by that logic Dwight in his
head is doing the calculus about how he
can get out of there or do something
else like get rid of negan so it was a
great episode about those two characters
about how they went from one end of the
spectrum to the other on negan like
Dwight was all about negan's the
beginning hates him by the end
Eugene slowly going to the dark side or
at least seeming like he went to the
dark side so let me know in the comments
do you actually think that that is
what's happening with his character do
you think that Eugene is pretending or
he's just being true to form he's a
super coward and he actually believes
some of the things that he's doing it
just seems like he's in complete coward
mode so he's not even thinking about it
like he's just doing exactly what he
needs to do to get people to feel like
he's necessary which is exactly what he
did when he first ran into Rick in their
group like he told them all these lies
so they think he was necessary
eventually it came out so eventually it
seems like the Savior's will find out
that he's lying - but what's going to
happen next is I have a DC TV video that
I'll post they're talking about the day
before Knight crossover so it's going to
be crazy I'll post that in the morning
then supply be some more Marvel I'm
thinking about making Mondays Marvel
Mondays so they'll be at least like 1
Marvel video no matter what's going on
so we'll see though congratulations to
last week's Walking Dead giveaway winner
Gabe Santiago please private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details so new DC TV
should be up relatively early in the
morning thank you so much for watching
what you guys wait for that you can
click here for new logan footage and you
can click here for all my other Walking
Dead videos thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you
guys in the next video